hello and welcome to this video as I
said back to back actually play him just
a moment ago I came down cut more than
one line that I can play against the
Trump and this is the sharp one that I
have in my repertoire
[Music]
people are people are often heavily
irritated by this line
especially once I played b5 I often you
retain myself I have the same
because I forget stuff
if b5 is audio it's your secure square
on c4 that is just helpful and you kind
of preempt 93
okay now him how was that working again
thinking is this is an insult it's
completely crazy
tank
yeah this is not good actually but yeah
you have to remember why so we'll check
Queen h4 g3 couldn't be for check I
think I can just grab everything but
that might be a wild ride
and this is something where it would be
helpful to to totally know everything I
have analyzed this and I think black is
okay but
I don't quite remember how they'd worked
out
if it doesn't play see three all that
makes no sense
what do I did so you have to place you
three and give up the exchange
no way around it I don't know what he's
thinking about here otherwise I just
play 94 and win I think I'm a much
better
so c3 Quinby - and then you have to take
on d6
or we click on b5 I cannot cancel no I I
think actually I had this on the board
once
[Music]
this is a moment where the cheetah I
would fire up chess base or chasuble and
just look at my repertoire I had this in
my in my banco gambit repertoire this is
I mean this is just weird because I mean
yeah I'm just better I think for like
just like without any problem
I'm just attacking me five and B two
when everything and it might be that I'm
better anyway but I don't quite remember
the verdict I just know that the line is
fine and I am also remembered that
remember the sequence and that it is
okay but I don't know if I'm actually
better there or not okay so c3 Queen a5
Queen to d6 I can play Knight to d7 and
then Queen b6 oh okay
F for I have to go to c6
I can also check here now but I'm giving
up b5 than in the process and I don't
know if I want to do that
hmm okay okay now if for I can check
yeah this is probably okay I can still
screw that up it's not
particularly simple this position so
kind of murky but on f4 I have 94 check
this is just the key thing and if I get
to play Queen to b6 and traitors I'm
fine anyway I don't want to do this
though and give them B 5 that would
Whitewood get away then okay here I can
take d2
can grab you fire
huh
you
you know maybe just Bishop to b7 just
develop
to really see a drawback to that move
you
really like completely much a way to
play that would be castling queenside
it's been that but it's a bit of a
show-off move
okay if I go just a six
[Music]
I can actually simply take him because I
mean the rook is hanging I didn't really
pay attention to that but you know I
know it's it's a show-off move but it's
not bad I think I'm threatening Knight
f6 and he's got no time on the clock who
came someone I have 625 room 52
it's not super Winningham
check
hmm okay that happens yeah with this
bloody show of moves I can't come on I'm
winning this still no not because of the
position anymore I lose on time
I'm still having many threats 90 for the
night is hanging and so on but that was
one basically out of the opening book
yeah I analyzed this for my bank
repertoire and the black is fine I
remember that for sure and this is no
good I think it was played against me
some time ago and this is for sure the
right start and here I thought the ac3
would be the move which I didn't think
would work on a sleep but I couldn't
remember the verdict we've been the
engine here with not a memory
I am 93 yeah now I know now I remember
actually I remember this and then nights
before cake and the B politics
I remember that wiki beep on and this
was was ok for black
I need to castle so he probably cannot
do this because this is too much
he's got not check a just he prevents my
castling but I'm just winning peace and
if I get to castle then 96 94 and the
bishop here will be enough play you have
to compensate for the somewhat hard
structure any plate king f2 and this
probably should not work that the engine
actually wants to play night between hmm
Queen B - I'm sorry
how much ever says the I just thought
I'm fine hear that splat played us and I
didn't really pay all that much
attention to capturing which is
definitely the best move this
yeah this is okay I'm white is okay it's
almost a transposition to the same
position time I can you play b3 and I
take the T a black should just be
winning and I can take c3 probably but
Luke c8 a6 yeah this this was
unnecessary it was just this wasn't what
I would have said it's just I mean your
chick show of move and it immediately
backfired a little bit on me i blundered
this but it is still a winner there's
too much going on I've got h6 I mean
okay first one hangs and it's Knight to
g4 stuff so if this happens I probably
have no g4 that looks pretty dreadful
also HS again h6 actually is the
simplest because he cannot go here I
simply take it like this I'm on the rook
and if he goes here I can take her
through yet yeah three because of that
pin again so I did not blunder with that
City cancelling but yeah the Queen takes
e5 was like oh I didn't see that one
okay guys thanks for watching